hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar validating a pharmaceutical
total organic carbon benchtop analyzer
to IC hq2 i am michelle ashton of lab
herbs and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by Beckman Coulter to learn more
about our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker Tony Harrison senior marketing
manager at Beckman Coulter for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
Tony you may now begin your presentation
excellent thank you very much for that
introduction
so hello everybody my name is Tony
Harrison and I am a product manager for
Beckman Coulter life sciences and today
I'm going to talk about validating a
pharmaceutical grade toc laboratory
analyzer to the International Committee
on harmonized carbonization procedure I
CH q 2 IC H Q 2 is written by
representatives representatives from the
United States Japanese and the European
pharmacopoeia
and against gain contains guidance on
how to ensure that a toc analyzer is fit
for purpose and for providing batch
release data IC h q 2 is taken on
special importance since it was
referenced in the FDA's December 2018
guidance on their 21 CFR part 11 data
integrity compliance a recent report
shows us in 2017 almost 75% of the FDA's
483 warning letters cited data integrity
issues and the main focus of these
letters was not security of the
electronic records themselves but in
fact the accuracy of the records they
are encouraging pharmaceutical industry
to improve their testing processes to
make them more robust to avoid the
natural human error that creeps in
during complex QC testing and introduces
error to the data records QC testing
instruments can be complex to configure
and operate and it is easy to make
mistakes which is why here at
Bettencourt o we've made our QbD 1,200
toc analyzer simple and straightforward
to configure and use
the QbD 1200 toc analyzer simple to use
we're helping pharmaceutical QC managers
to reduce their training burdens and by
all-out persecuting by allowing the user
to program their standard operating
procedure their SOP into the q VD 1200
and automating it we ensure that the SOP
is followed every time and again
reducing human errors and avoiding
problems with elip the inaccuracies in
the electronic records
here
culture we manufacture a range of QC
instrumentation that have all been
optimized to provide robust QC testing
for the pharmaceutical industry all of
them allow the user to program in and
automate their standard operating
procedures helping to avoid human errors
and reducing the operator required skill
level so the QC managers and manager
doesn't need to have highly skilled
operators carrying out routine and
repetitive QC tests our instruments
cover a range of parameters from toc
analysis to mammalian cell concentration
and health clean room air monitoring
final injectable drug quality testing
and stability testing for protein based
biologics
hundred analyzers is designed
specifically to suit the pharmaceutical
QC application it can hours analyze TOC
levels from 0.4 ppb to up to a hundred
thousand ppb it uses the industry
standard UV and persulphate method and
can handle up to 64 vials in the
autosampler at a time as I mentioned the
proof of the atomic appeal tests are in
there and you can pre-program your
standard operating routine into it and
then you simply select the SOP or the
camp and your test like system
suitability using an intuitive icon
driven menu
so any analysis the first that we do is
we acidify the water sample this
encourages any totally inorganic carbon
which is typically made up from carbon
dioxide dissolved in the water and it
gets that totally inorganic carbon out
of solution and into the water as a gas
and then we use a carrier gas to
actually sparge or purge the carbon
dioxide from the total inorganic carbon
out of solution where it's measured
using a non-dispersive infrared detector
and we report the TI sea
next step is a strong UV light turned on
and this releases that with this tries
to release the carbon atoms in the
organic material present in the sample
the organic material is oxidized by a
combination of pi hydroxyl radicals from
the water itself and by persulphate
which in the presence of the UV light
forms a very strong oxidizer and then
the toc is reduced really sorry as
carbon dioxide gas and then the third
step is a direct measurement of that toc
so the carbon dioxide from the the TOC
is sparged out or swept out from the
solution using the purge gas and it's
measured by the non-dispersive infrared
detector so we wait till all the TI see
the dissolved carbon dioxide from the TI
c is gone so and then we turn the UV
lamp on and that's when we start to
oxidize the organics and then we measure
the carbon dioxide from that so you make
sure there's no interference from the TI
sea
a documented IQ oq n PQ procedure
available and it's the PQ section we're
going to talk about today because that
is the one carries out the required
testing to validate the QbD 1202 the IC
HQ to guidelines
for those who are not familiar with it I
see hq2
is in fact the International Conference
on harmonization
and they they're working to harmonize
the pharmacopoeias between European
United States and Japan Japanese and
they also produce guidance such as the
icy HQ to guidance
sowhat's I see HQ to itself well there's
various parameters that they recommend
or attributes they recommend and they
give guidance on these attributes and
they ensure that they're tested to make
sure the instrument is suitable for
pharmaceutical testing application
it covers instruments accuracy precision
specificity limit of detection and
quantitation linearity range and finally
robustness
take a look at each of those attributes
in detail and how the PQ for the QED
1200 demonstrates compliance I CH q2
suggests that instruments accuracy can
be best demonstrated by examining
examining the instruments response to a
certified reference standard the QbD
1200 PQ uses a certified potassium
hydrogen select solution containing five
parts per million of total organic
carbon automated onboard dilution allows
comparison against the standard at five
points across the measurement range and
the test SOP is preloaded into the QED
and automated and simply selected from
an icon on the screen
although the US the United States
Pharmacopeia in the European
pharmacopoeia don't specify the
calibration solution to be used on TOC
analyzers the Japanese pharmacopoeia
does Japanese pharmacopoeia requires
potassium hydrogen if a light to used
hence by using this the QbD can be seen
to comply completely with all the
pharmacopoeias globally
good accuracy is demonstrated by
comparing its response to five different
levels of toc from that certified
standard and the pass/fail calculation
is automated and avoids manual
calculations and human error
i CH cutest guess that precision can be
assessed by comparing multiple analyses
of the same sample it suggests three
replicates of three different
concentrations of toc and the PQ from
the q BD 1200 follows this guidance
exactly by doing three replicates each
of one two three four and 5 ppm
concentrations of toc solution
the QED 1200 against this precision test
is calculated automatically in a
pass/fail generated
a quick word on
precision in this diagram we're
explaining the difference between these
two
the first dashboard showed that our
dartboard sorry first dartboard shows
what happens when you have neither
accuracy nor precision the results of
these repeated tests are all over the
place and no any other that what we'd
like to see the second dartboard shows
excellent precision with very repeatable
results but it's not very accurate it's
got poor accuracy but high precision the
third dart board shows relatively good
accuracy in the sense that the results
are clustered around the bullseye
but the precision is poor as the results
are not consistent they vary quite a lot
and finally the last star board that's
exactly what we want where the
instrument has got both good accuracy
and high precision with the results on
target and reproducible
specificity test demonstrates that the
toc analyzer can measure and report TOC
accurately in the presence of
potentially interfering substances that
may be present in the sample now this is
demonstrated by carrying out two tests
one is a system suitability test to
ensure the TOC analyzer can successfully
analyze the full range of organic
materials expected to be present in
pharmaceutical grade water and secondly
by demonstrating the analyzer can
successfully report.toc in the presence
of large amounts of total inorganic
carbon in the form of dissolved carbon
dioxide
now most FARC appears determined the
range of organics life is present in the
sample can be covered by testing using
sucrose and benzoquinone and this test
is pre-loaded and automated with
automatic pass/fail in the system
however the Japanese pharmacopoeias
justice specificity can be demonstrated
by the successful analysis of fdbs
and again that test is built into the
analyzer and could be selected from a
simple button on the screen
the second part of the specificity test
that we do on the QED 1200 is to test it
in the presence of very high levels with
total on you're going carbon by
completely sparging it from the sample
before we measure the TOC so we put a
sample in which contains high levels of
T IC and we make sure this doesn't
interfere with the measurement
so we don't turn our UV lamp on to start
the TOC analysis until we are ready to
do that we've got rid of all the tea I
see from the sample
so toc analyzers used to separate
sensors to measure T IC and then total
carbon cancer for bad knee in fact in
samples containing large amounts of T IC
in the form of dissolve carbon dioxide
and in fact that's very common to have
large amounts of dissolved carbon
dioxide especially in purified water
samples small errors in each of these
sensors the measurement can actually
cause really large offsets in the
reported TOC and even lead to negative
TOC results
GOC analyzers that use the two sensors
to calculate the toc they calculated by
subtracting the measured token in
organic carbon from the total carbon
that they measure
you can see on this screen here's a
common toc analyzer found on the market
and you can see it's actually measuring
IC in organic carbon that is and total
carbon is calculating the toc in this
particular case the purified water
contains twelve point three parts per
million of Ti see it's reporting that
calculated soy calculated TOC value is
600 parts per billion but however the
sensors that are making these
calculations actually have a plus or
minus 2 percent tolerance on the two
sensors which means that has these two
sensors drift away from each other I
plus or minus 2% the reported values of
T IC and TC can vary tremendously so the
actual level of TOC presence rule
reported could be anywhere between 96
parts per billion and 1104 ppb
sent torrents on the QbD single sensor
means that when it actually does a
measurement it's actually using the same
sensor to make both measurements so
potentially if you've got a hundred say
for instance a hundred parts per billion
of toç in your sample then you'll get a
plus or minus four ppb maximum error on
that sample measurement
now the limit of detection is that in
fact the smallest amount of a substance
is any analyzer can detect it might not
necessarily have to report it though and
that's where limit of quantitation comes
in this is the smallest amount of a
substance that the analyzer will not
only detect but will actually accurately
measure and report
now the performance qualification
follows the I CH q2 q2 guidance on how
to calculate the limit of detection and
limit of quantitation so these are
calculated values it's almost impossible
in the field to demonstrate the limits
of detection and quantitation because
the levels of toc are so low you can't
get calibration standards that low so
they're calculated the linearity test
determines the ability of an analyzer to
report accurately over a range for
analyses the PQ for QbD 1200
demonstrates this by showing the linear
performance of the QBE 1200 across a
range of measurements
put the TOC standard through and we look
at the response from the analyzer for
multiple points across the measurement
range and the pass/fail calculation is
automated in the analyzer says no manual
calculations and the hence we try to
eliminate human error
now the range of the QbD 1200 is
demonstrated by testing in the
measurement range and then explained
that higher levels of toc are analyzed
through automatic sample dilution using
a calibrated syringe pump accurate to
plus or minus 1%
now it's important to realize that the
the TOC we report in parts per billion
and actually what that's equivalent to
is one microgram per liter of water and
of course a liter of water is 1 kilogram
if it's all really ultra pure water so
we were reporting 1 microgram in one
kilogram now it's important to
understand that's what we're measuring
here because if you've got to say a 1
liter sample of water containing a
hundred thousand parts per billion of
TOC if you dilute that with another one
liter of TOC free water the TOC level is
half because now we've got twice the
amount of water with the same amount of
carbon so now would report 50,000 ppb so
using this we can now use dilution to
allow us to measure higher levels of TOC
in samples up to 4000 ppb the dilution
is not required as the amount of
persulphate added automatically each
time by the QED 1200 will successfully
analyze this level of toc however above
4000 parts per billion
the QbD at 1200 automatically determines
the amount of per sulfate to add so the
user does not need to guess
the ability to measure successfully
despite variations in the sample
characteristics and the way we do to
demonstrate that with the PQ for the QED
1200 is by testing the QED 1200 with
samples where the pH has deliberately
been altered so we put the same level of
TOC in with different pH values and
check that it will still measure despite
this variation
now intermediate precision is an
interesting one
what they're talking about here is the
effect of random events on the precision
of the analytical procedure what they're
referencing really here is having
different analysts use the machine and
and the way they use the machine might
give slightly different results so it
gives you a differing result depending
on what technician is and spending on
those skill level as well and the way we
actually demonstrate compliance to this
with the QbD 1200 is we actually
automate the SOP so the entrance
automatically configured correctly every
time so the user doesn't configure the
Machine and also we automate the
addition of the sulfate to ensure the
TOC analysis is analyzed correctly now
that might seem obvious but in some TOC
analyzers particularly those using a
carbon dioxide permeable membrane as
part of a measurement process the users
have to guess how much per sulfate to
add in other words they need to know the
level of TOC present in the sample
before they carry out the analysis how
can they know that the problem is you
see using these membrane based
technology and they add too much of a
sulfate for the amount of TOC presence
present sorry bubbles form in the in the
analysis chamber and this blocks the
carbon dioxide permeable membranes
causing the TOC analyzer to underreport
because the carbon dioxide doesn't go
through the membrane now equally if they
put doing so if they don't add enough
the sulfate for the level of TOC in the
sample the TOC will not be fully
oxidized and again the TOC analyzer will
under report
finally the PQ demonstrates its
robustness by being unaffected by gas
bubbles in the sample if you remember I
mentioned the membrane permeable ones if
they get bubbles in the sample it blocks
the membrane and the carbon dioxides not
measured correctly but in this case the
we measure the C carbon dioxide using a
non-dispersive infrared which is
selective to measuring only carbon
dioxide so it doesn't matter if there
are bubbles of other gas present and the
standard amount of persulfate we add
covers even the widest range of toc
analysis required in pharmaceutical
grade water in other words up to 4000
ppb of toc and of course the pass/fail
criteria in the pharmacopoeia is 500 ppb
so we should be coping with the maximum
amount of toc that you'll find in your
sample
so that brings me to the end of my
presentation today and thank you for
listening in and if you've got any
questions please submit them now thank
you Tony for your presentation we will
now be pushing out a poll question which
will show up on your screen we
appreciate your participation
okay we will now get started with the
live Q&A session a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of the
presentation window labeled ask the
question and click on the send button
honey will answer as many questions as
time permits alright let's get started
our first question is why is it
important to validate a POC analyzer - i
CH q - yeah no certainly I mean most
validation packages that you get with us
- an off-the-shelf type of
instrumentation it really validates the
machine works correctly and it does what
it's supposed to do but in fact if
you're using a QC laboratory TOC
analyzer to provide data for the batch
release file then it should be validated
for that application and that's where I
see I see HQ - comes and it provides
sufficient evidence acceptable to the
regulatory inspectors from the United
States European and the Japanese
regulatory bodies that the QC lab at lab
analyze is fit for that for that use
great thank you okay next question how
does having single sensor technology
help the QbD 1200 avoid interference
from high levels of total and organic
carbon certainly yet so the problem
we're trying to avoid really is in you
know in TOC analyzers use two separate
sensors to measure total carbon and
total inorganic carbon and the problem
is with two sensors a small drafting
calibration between the sensors can lead
to measurement errors which will impact
on the accuracy if the calculated TOC or
total organic carbon what we do with the
QED 1200 we trap an aliquot to the water
sample we measure the total inorganic
carbon by spurted sparging out the
carrier gas and then we oxidize the
sample to measure TOC with the same
sensor so any drift in the single sensor
will affect both the measurement of the
total inorganic carbon and the total
organic carbon so it affects it'll
affect both measurements and effectively
cancels the drift out
you how does the QbD 1200 avoid the
effects of human error on the
intermediate precision as mentioned in
IC HQ - yeah good question so as I
mentioned the intermediate precision is
really looking to see what effect can be
made on the measurements between
different operators who are configuring
the machine slightly differently or
configuring the sample or things like
that so what we've done is we simplify
the instrument setup we reduce the
configuration steps so we're not having
to decide how much persulfate to adds
the correct amount and that reduces the
opportunities for human error and that
human error can occur more calm more
regularly in more complex lab toc
analyzers and so also the benefit of
that is we're reducing the need for
continuous training to operate the
instrument and for the benefit for the
QC manager is reducing the skill set
that the operator needs so you're not
having a highly trained technicians
doing repetitive mundane QC testing you
can D skill it effectively and program
the SOP and just select it from an icon
so the whole point is by simplifying the
instrument we've reduced the effect of
operator to operator skill levels and
hence reduce the intermediate precision
errors as outlined in Ice Age q2
I would like to once again in Tony for
his time today do you have any final
comments for our audience no just to say
thank you to everybody for sitting in
and listening I hope you found it useful
thank you I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions any questions that were
submitted that we did not have time for
today will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration we would
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Beckman Coulter for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand laberd's will alert you
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
thanks bye